Traductor: Patricia Riveira
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En los caminos polvorientos de una aldea
un vendedor ambulante estaba teniendo
problemas para vender sus mercancías.
Había recorrido la zona
hacía solo unas pocas semanas,
y la mayoría de los aldeanos
ya habían visto sus productos.
Así que deambuló por
las afueras del pueblo
con la esperanza de encontrar
algunos clientes nuevos.
Por desgracia, el camino estaba
en gran parte vacío,
y el vendedor estaba
a punto de dar media vuelta,
cuando escuchó un aullido agudo
que venía de la linde del bosque.
Siguiendo los gritos hasta su fuente,
descubrió  a un tanuki atrapado.
Aunque estas criaturas parecidas a
mapaches eran conocidas por su astucia,
este parecía aterrorizado e indefenso.
El vendedor liberó a la criatura en apuros
pero antes de que pudiese ocuparse de
sus heridas, escapó hacia la maleza.
Al día siguiente, partió
en su ruta habitual.
Mientras caminaba fatigosamente,
vio una tetera tirada.
Estaba oxidada y vieja... pero quizás
podría venderla a los monjes del lugar.
El vendedor la pulió hasta que brilló.
Llevó la tetera hasta el templo Morin-ji
y se la ofreció a los solemnes monjes.
Fue el momento oportuno...
necesitaban una tetera grande
para un oficio importante,
y compraron su tetera
por un generoso precio.
Para abrir la ceremonia, empezaron a
servir tazas de té a cada monje...
pero la tetera se enfrió demasiado rápido.
Tuvo que ser recalentada muchas veces
durante el largo oficio,
y cuando estaba caliente, parecía que
se retorcía en la mano del vertedor.
Al final de la ceremonia, los monjes
se sintieron engañados por su compra,
y llamaron al vendedor para que
volviese y se explicase.
A la mañana siguiente,
el vendedor revisó el recipiente,
pero no pudo encontrar
nada inusual en él.
Esperando que una taza de té
les ayudase a pensar,
pusieron la tetera en el fuego.
En pocos instantes,
el metal empezó a sudar.
De repente, brotaron una cola cubierta de
maleza, patas peludas y nariz puntiaguda.
Con un aullido, el vendedor reconoció
al tanuki que había liberado.
El vendedor estaba sorprendido.
Había oído historias del tanuki
que cambiaba de forma
que se transformaba al tirar
de sus testículos.
Pero eran generalmente
bromistas problemáticos,
que gastaban bromas
vergonzosas a viajeros,
o hacían llover dinero
que después se convertía en hojas.
Algunas personas incluso ponían estatuas
de tanukis fuera de sus casas y comercios
para engañar a posibles bromistas
y llevarse sus travesuras a otra parte.
Sin embargo, el tanuki sonreía dulcemente.
¿Por qué había elegido
esta forma insospechada?
El tanuki explicó que quería
recompensar la amabilidad del vendedor.
Sin embargo, se había calentado demasiado
como una tetera,
y no le gustaba ser quemado,
restregado, o pulido.
El monje y el vendedor se rieron, ambos
impresionados por este honorable bromista.
A partir de ese día, el tanuki se volvió
un invitado apreciado del templo.
Podía ser encontrado a menudo
contando historias y realizando trucos
que divertían incluso
a los monjes más serios.
Los aldeanos venían desde muy lejos
para ver al tanuki del templo
y el vendedor iba a menudo de visita para
compartir té hecho con una tetera normal.